j'avais appliqué pour une assurance vie
c'est un bilan de santé qui ne devait
être qu'une formalité pour marc maillet
mais le résultat a causé la surprise et
changer sa vie il la découvre et caméras
fonctionnant pour bien que je vende
maladies du rein je n'avais aucune idée
que j'avais des problèmes les années ont
passé serra ont cessé de fonctionner la
dialyse est devenu nécessaire en attente
d'une greffe une attente qui a duré
trois ans faut toujours que tu restes au
tour dans ce cadre les deux jours taux
d'intérêt de l'hôpital pour tout
traitement ainsi de suite alors ce
comité toute ta vie fall tour de ton
horaire de dialyse s'attaque la famille
ça fait que tout le monde autour de toi
mais vous dans une nouvelle vie depuis
le dont la
très actif pour lui mais surtout pour
tous ceux qui vivent à leur tour dans la
tente le nouveau programme de dons
d'organes la province est porteur
d'espoir au coeur de la réforme le
principe de consentement présumé
avec cette nouvelle loi on considère que
tous ceux dans la province qui répondent
aux exigences médicales ont consenti au
don d'organes explique le médecin
responsable du programme
ceux qui s'y opposent peuvent ajouter
leurs noms enregistre les proches d'un
défunt sont aussi toujours consulter
pour s'assurer que la personne n'avait
jamais exprimé de son vivant un malaise
lié aux dons d'organes
un autre objectif du programme en
vigueur depuis le début de 2021 c'est
que le nombre de donneurs reflète mieux
le taux d'appui au don d'organes qui est
exprimé dans la population l'an passé
155 d'honneur de tissus comme des
cornées ou des valves cardiaques ont été
recensés en nouvelle écosse une hausse
de 40% par rapport à 2020 28 personnes
décédées ont aussi été identifiés comme
potentiel donneur d'organes consentant
des chiffres encourageants mais
révélateur de l'ampleur du défi qui
porte un voile
mais c'est soit
5 de
plus de 57 mille personnes ont quant à
elles officiellement refusé que leurs
organes soient prélevés c'est environ 6%
de la population soit moins que ce que
les responsables du programme avait
prévu mais même un an après son adoption
bien des néo écossais ignorent encore
l'existence de nouvelles lois êtes vous
au courant du programme de consentement
présumé depuis l'an passé pour le don
d'organes
non
une méconnaissance qui ne rassure pas
cette experte c'est cela justement les
anges et pour
certaines personnes on prélève aux
deux mois
d'autres provinces canadiennes
envisagent aussi d'adopter le
consentement présumé ce qui appuie le
principe les pressent d'agir adopter
cette nouvelle loi si ça peut sauver
deux personnes pour moi çà çà çà çà pour
athènes et rappelle qu'en 2020 seulement
276 canadiens sont décédés en attente de
dons d'organes
si matthew papillon radio canada à
halifax